DAVID TU: Hey, everyone.
David Tu here.
And I'm excited to
be back to share
some updates on
our new JA launches
for load balancing and
service networking.
Stick around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We'll kick off this
video discussing
new features available for both
internal and external HTTPS
load balancer.
This feature enables you
to test URL maps that
has already been deployed.
As a refresher, a URL map
is a configuration resource
that routes requests to backend
services or backend buckets.
For example, example.com/video
can go to one backend service.
Example.com/audio can go to
a different backend service.
And example.com/images can go to
a Cloud Storage backend bucket.
Not only can you use URL
maps to route traffic
based on the path, but you can
also route based on the host.
This flexibility is crucial
for traffic engineering,
but could get overwhelming
in validations.
With this launch, you
can easily configure
tests to verify whether
a specific URL are
hitting the expected backend.
When running a test, we
will identify the backend
you expect versus the backend
that traffic will actually
be routed to.
Moving on to the internal
network load balancer,
we have several
updates to share.
We'll start off
with an enhancement
when using the internal network
load balancer as a next hop
for routing.
For context, you can
create a static route,
which sends traffic to
an internal network load
balancer as the next hop.
In this example, we're using the
internal network load balancer
to balance traffic between
multiple NAT gateways
that route traffic
to the internet.
This was available
only for TCP and UDP.
With this launch, we now
support all protocols,
which allows for more
functionality and easier
troubleshooting.
Next feature is
something crucial
when deploying stateful virtual
appliances in Google Cloud,
symmetric hashing.
Prior to this launch,
whenever deploying
stateful virtual appliances
in a highly available manner,
it would require
source NAT to ensure
the return traffic would
be properly routed back
to the same appliance.
With the launch of
symmetric hashing,
we simplified operations for
stateful virtual appliances
by guaranteed traffic of the
same flow gets the same hash.
In other words, the
hash doesn't change
when the source IP and port is
swapped with the destination
IP and port.
This ensures the
return traffic hits
a corresponding
virtual appliance
and removes the
requirement for source NAT.
Lastly, for the internal
network load balancer,
we've added some functionality
for UDP protocol session
affinity.
Prior to this launch,
only TCP sessions
supported two-tuple and
three-tuple session affinity.
Now the internal
network load balancer
can ensure UDP connections from
the same source and destination
IP or source and destination
IP and protocol go
to the same backend instance.
Saving what I'm most excited to
share for last, Private Service
Connect.
Private Service Connect
enables private consumption
of services across
VPCs belonging
to different groups, teams,
projects, or organizations.
It is simple, scalable, and
secure, since the traffic never
goes over the internet.
You may recall my previous
episode covered Private Service
Connect for Google APIs.
That update allowed users
to create custom endpoints
for Google APIs.
This update is to use Private
Service Connect to publish
and consume services.
Private Service Connect
solves many of the caveats
that current private VPC-to-VPC
solutions, like VPC peering,
introduce.
With Private Service Connect,
IP addressing and IP usage
is drastically simplified.
Consumers and producers
don't need to share quotas
and limits, and it allows
for overlapping addresses
between the VPCs.
Private Service
Connect also allows
for multitenant services.
This means different
consumers can connect
to a multitenant service.
With Private Service
Connect, producers
can significantly scale in
a private and secure manner.
This gives flexibility
to a SaaS provider,
as it enables easy and
secure private connectivity.
And that's a wrap
for this episode
of "What's New in Networking."
Thanks for tuning in to learn
about our new load balancing
and service networking updates.
Make sure to take a
look at the links below.
Stay tuned for the next episode
of "What's New in Networking."
[MUSIC PLAYING]